on both sides of the board  and uh okay first we see a trade of  pawns  you can even move the white king up the  board now yeah move the white king  rip two squares as you kind of  highlighted  and uh  i agree ten seconds is more than enough  with the increment here gaining 10  seconds after every move he can build up  a lot of time here yeah exactly like you  say you just make non moves and uh and  we're going to see checkmate on the  board  mishra celebrates checkmate next move  the black king  trapped and there we go we have a result  it is over wow what an impressive  performance by 13 year old abby monument  not only did he win his game against  eric hansen here he is also winning  against one of the top 10 players in the  world and let's see  is this live of abi manu mishra  just looking at the game not even  celebrating such a smile  you can see it